once we are happy with our train machine
learning model how can we serve up
predictions at scale find out on this
episode of cloudy adventures Google's
cloud machine learning engine enables
you to create a prediction service for
your tensorflow model without any ops
work get more time with your data by
going from a train model to a deployed
auto scaling prediction service in a
matter of minutes so we've gathered our
data and finally finish training up a
suitable model and validating that it
performs well so now we're ready to move
to the second phase serving those
predictions when taking on the challenge
of serving predictions we would ideally
want to deploy a model that is
purpose-built for serving in particular
a fast lightweight model that is static
since we don't need to do any updating
while serving predictions additionally
if we want our prediction server to
scale with demand that adds another
layer of complexity to the problem it
turns out that tensorflow
already has a built-in function that can
take care of generating an optimized
model for serving predictions it handles
all the adjustments needed which saves
you a lot of work the function that
we're interested in is called export
saved model and we can run it directly
from our classifier object once we're
satisfied with the state of the trained
model this will take a snapshot of your
model and export it as a set of files
that you can use elsewhere over time as
your model improves you can continue to
produce exported models in order to
provide multiple versions these exported
files are made up of a file and a folder
the file is called saved model PB which
defines the model structure the
variables folder holds two files
supplying the trained weights in our
model once you have an exported model
you're ready to serve it in production
here are your two primary options you
can use tensorflow serving or the cloud
machine learning engine prediction
service tensorflow serving is a part of
tensorflow and available on github
however today we will focus our
attention on cloud machine learning
engines prediction service though they
both have very similar file interfaces
cloud machine learning engine allows you
to take this exported model and turn
into a prediction service with a
built-in endpoint and auto scaling which
goes all the way down to zero it's also
complete with a feature-rich command
line tool API and UI so we can interact
with it in a number of ways depending on
our preferences let's see an example how
to use cloud machine learning engines
prediction service with our Irish sample
first we will run export save model on
our trained classifier this will
generate an exported model that we can
use for our prediction service next
we'll upload those files to Google cloud
storage cloud machine learning engine
will read from cloud storage when
creating a new model version be sure to
choose the regional storage class and to
ensure that your compute and storage are
in the same region in the cloud machine
learning engine UI we can create a new
model which is really just a ma wrapper
for our released versions versions hold
our individual export models while the
model abstraction helps route the
incoming traffic to the appropriate
version of your choice here we are in
the models ListView where we can create
a new model all it takes to create a
model is to just give it a name let's
calls ours iris model next we'll create
a version by choosing a name for this
particular model version and pointing it
to our cloud storage directory that
holds our exported files and just like
that we've created our model all it took
was pointing the service and our
exported model and giving it a name how
could it take so little work well the
service handled all the operational
aspects of setting up and securing the
endpoint
moreover we didn't need to write our own
code for scaling out based on demand and
since this is the cloud this elasticity
means you don't need to pay for unused
compute when demand is low by setting up
a prediction service for our iris model
that didn't need any ops work we've been
able to go from train model to deployed
auto scaling prediction service in a
matter of minutes which means more time
to get back to working with your data
thanks for watching this episode of
cloud a I adventures be sure to
subscribe to the channel to catch all
the latest episodes as they come out
also check out the links at the bottom
for a cool talk from the tensorflow team
and don't forget when it comes to
scaling your machine
learning service in production cloud
machine learning engines got your back
[Music]
thanks for watching that episode of
cloud AI adventures you can catch the
whole series here and if you have any
thoughts and comments feel free to leave
them down below